et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
stéphane troussel bonjour bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous au président
socialiste du conseil départemental de
la seine saint denis en étant 100
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour pascal jalabert ni du
groupe ebra les journaux régionaux de
l'est de la france on commence bien sûr
stéphane troussel en parlant de la crise
sanitaire et de la vaccination puisque
le gouvernement mise beaucoup là-dessus
promet une accélération de la
vaccination va revenir sur les mesures
gouvernementales mais d'abord il ya six
jours
ouvrez le plus grand vaccinodromes de
france celui du stade de france dans
votre département six jours après quel
est le bilan
écoutez moi j'ai considéré que
l'ouverture du grand centre de
vaccination au stade de france c'était
le signal enfants tout cas je veux le
croire
c'est le signal de l'accélération enfin
de la vaccination dans notre pays
selon moi la politique vaccinale elle
doit marcher sur ses deux jambes à la
fois les centres de proximité il y en a
25 ans seine-saint-denis le préfet de
man annonce même manus même quelques
ouvertures supplémentaires et les grands
centres de vaccination pour vacciner le
plus grand nombre
quand enfin il dort à l'élargissement et
les centres de proximité pour permettre
à ce que nos concitoyens les plus
fragiles les moins mobiles est une
solution de vaccination près de chez eux
et donc cette première semaine qui a
démarré donc mardi
l'ouverture était prévue donc jusqu'à
samedi soir
elle reprend ce matin ces onze mille
personnes vaccinées avec l'objectif que
nous avions fixé la moitié de ces
couanau dionysien d'habitants de la
seine-saint-denis pour qui nous avons
mis en place un standard téléphonique
dédié un centre d'appels qui fonctionne
avec une cinquantaine d'étudiants que le
département a recruté parce qu'on avait
constaté dans les premiers jours de la
vaccination mois de janvier que l'accès
aux pour les habitants la seine saint
denis dans les centres de proximité
était parfois rendu difficile par les
l'utilisation exclusive des plateformes
numériques pour ça que nous avons ouvert
aussi ce centre téléphonique dédiée aux
habitants de zentane
avez vous suffisamment de doses avez
vous suffisamment de créneaux et voyez
vous montez un doute sur ce fameux
vaccin astrazeneca
alors écoutez en tout cas encore une
fois l'ouverture de ce centre de
vaccination au stade de france
en plus des centres existants je veux y
voir le fait que nous allons enfin
recevoir davantage de doses
il y en a eu la semaine dernière autant
que la semaine précédente dans les
centres de vaccination de proximité et
il y a eu donc ces onze mille doses
supplémentaires au stade de france je
hais ce que vous savez combien vous
allez recevoir deux doses dans les
prochaines heures en tout cas ce centre
de vaccination au stade de france
il est calibré pour l'instant à environ
dix mille doses supplémentaires
toutes les semaines mais si vous n'avez
pas d'informations contradictoires
l'écart est en tout cas en fin de
semaine dernière il y avait dix mille
créneau ouvert pour cette semaine et il
a la capacité en terme d'organisation
tel que nous l'avons calibré avec
l'ensemble de nos partenaires la ville
de saint denis la rs les pompiers la
croix rouge
le département pour être en capacité
d'en accueillir vingt mille trente mille
si besoin
non non on vous demande ça parce qu'on
avait le maire de marseille vendredi
bruno bâillon qui nous dit que lui il a
eu des mauvaises nouvelles de son
adresse et qu'il ne recevra pas le
nombre de doses espérer est-ce que vous
c'est pas le bon moment où je vous parle
en tout cas ce n'est pas le cas au
moment où je vous parle geste j'espère
bien en tout cas compte tenu de la
situation compte tenu des compris moi je
le dis j'ai nous avons fait des
propositions pour
justement élargir cette vaccination dans
un département comme la seine saint
denis où le taux d'incidence est élevé
reste élevé même s'il semble se
stabiliser même diminué un peu ces
derniers jours mais il reste très élevé
par rapport à la moyenne nationale c'est
le quart en seine saint denis c'est le
cas également dans un département voisin
comme le val d'oise moi par exemple je
considère qu'il faudrait profiter de ces
semaines de fermeture des établissements
scolaires des écoles collèges et lycées
des établissements de la petite enfance
par exemple pour vacciner tous ces
professionnels en première ligne les
professionnels de la petite enfance les
enseignants comme les personnels de
restauration des entretiens pour que
quand les établissements vont rouvrir à
la fin avril et bien ça se fasse en
toute sérénité et vous avez d'ailleurs
au premier ministre le week-end dernier
sur ce sujet vous l'avez vue mardi et
oui au stade de france est qu'est-ce qui
vous a répondu là dessus et écouter pour
l'instant je n'ai pas dre de réponse
favorable j'ai entendu des évolutions
sur le fait que par exemple il pourrait
y avoir une une priorisation pour les
intervenants les enseignants qui
interviennent en direction des enfants
porteurs de handicap vous faudrait
encore précisé decaux manque de quoi il
s'agit est ce que c'est dans des équipes
interviennent en demies en établissement
spécialisé en établissement ordinaire
et puis surtout je considère qu'il faut
davantage territorialisée la politique
vaccinale
ce n'est pas la même situation
dans certes dans un certain nombre de
départements et donc concentrer nos
efforts dans les départements où
l'épidémie fait rage ça me semble être
une mesure de bon sens une mesure de
justice sanitaire même donc ça veut dire
que l'ouverture aux plus de 55 ans dès
aujourd'hui uniquement avec astrazeneca
et le vaccin de johnson & johnson a on
précise vous dit c'est pas suffisant
vous dites il faut encore aller plus
loin oui oui notamment je vous le dis
c'est professionnel en première ligne en
dans un département comme le nôtre mais
c'est vrai aussi dans d'autres
départements et le ce sont chez les
jeunes actifs que cette contamination
est forte et où le virus circule
activement et donc pour briser les
chaînes de contamination il faut
effectivement adapter notre stratégie
vaccinale à jour du assuré départ et
est-ce que par exemple au stade de
france il ya encore des créneaux libres
où tous les créneaux sont déjà occupés
par les personnes qui sont prioritaires
à l'heure actuelle en tout cas
ce matin il y à des créneaux pour la
semaine et j'invite d'ailleurs les
habitants de la seine-saint-denis a
utilisé le numéro de téléphone qui leur
est dédiée le j'en profite pour faire sa
publicité le 01 43 93 78 77
oui il y à des créneaux cette semaine
pour se faire vacciner dès lors pour
rendre dans les catégories éligibles à
la vaccination
aujourd'hui alors un dernier mot juste
sur ce sujet pour finir parce que vous
nous parler des centres de proximité
vous avez entendu 1 cm requis 10 mai le
vaccinaux donne du stade de france ils
aspirent nos doses et se fait au
détriment des centres de proximité
qu'est ce que vous répondez h à écouter
d'abord moi je suis encore une fois je
les dis je suis favorable à ce que la
politique vaccinale elle marche sur ses
deux jambes des centres de proximité et
encore une fois le préfet m'annonce que
d'autres centres de laxisme de proximité
un ou deux pourraient être ouverts en
plus de ceux déjà existants en plus du
bus de la vaccination qui circulent en
seine-saint-denis qu'organisait le
département en plus du centre de la
caisse primaire d'assurance maladie qui
vaccine les plus les personnes des
assurés sociaux les plus précaires et
donc voilà c'est la proximité mais aussi
des grands centres de vaccination dans
les chiffres qui ont été communiqués
si je compare par exemple la semaine du
début mars à la première semaine du mois
d'avril
eh bien le nombre de doses dans les
centres de proximité a même légèrement
augmenté donc ce n'est pas les remonter
les chiffres précis qu'on m'a donnée
pour kiki qui irait dans dans cette
analyse
un mot sur les hôpitaux et la
réanimation voit-on seine-saint-denis
les premiers effets positifs du
confinement qui a été anticipé
victoire vous savez bien qu'il ya
toujours un effet retard
nous sommes plutôt en ce moment dans le
dans le pic de la situation c'est-à-dire
que le nombre de contaminations est
excessivement élevés si le taux
d'incidence commence simplement à
diminuer ces jours ci on voit bien qu'il
va y avoir au contraire une dizaine de
jours dans l'acide dans le milieu
hospitalier qui vont être
particulièrement tendu et donc il y as
besoin que nos soignants soit soient
soutenus face à cette situation parce
qu'au contraire j'ai le nombre de lits
de réanimation de réanimation occupés
par des patients que l'idée est très
élevé les capacités sont dépassés je
précise que la seine-saint-denis à moins
de lits de réanimation que les
départements voisins alors même qu'elle
est le département le deuxième
département le plus peuplé après paris
en ile de france
le taux d'incidence a baissé quand même
il semble légèrement se stabiliser voire
même régressé c'est tout derniers jours
donc c'est à dire que les mesures
sélectives ou l'image étant moins
d'argent mais il faut surtout continuer
absolument à la fois de d'appliquer les
gestes barrière de porter ce masque nous
nous portons désormais sur votre plateau
et vous avez raison
mais il faut aussi vacciner vacciner et
vacciné encore les dîners clandestins
commencer ça a été perçu chez vous il ya
même une descente à saint-ouen dans vos
départements vous condamner ces
pratiques bien évidemment que je les
condamne
ils sont ils sont totalement condamnable
je pense à la fois ces restaurateurs qui
ont dû fermer qui subissent une baisse
d'activité une baisse de leur chiffre
d'affaires qui sont mises en difficulté
qui te respecte les règles donc c'est
absolument insupportable
et puis par ailleurs tous ceux qui s'y
l'hymne d'une manière ou d'une autre
quelle que soit leur position c'est
c'est s'est particulièrement indigné
alors que nos concitoyens les
restaurateurs mais l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens ont supprimé les aides de
l'état aux restaurateurs qui auraient
fraudé
oh oui bah bien évidemment bien
évidemment c'est encore une fois y
compris al ghalia de l'exemplarité a
donné on ne peut pas demander des
efforts à nos concitoyens qui les font
ces efforts parce que depuis un an que
cette épidémie dur et bien ils ont
globalement appliquer les règles nos
concitoyens et donc oui je pense qu'il
faut être particulièrement ferme dans
les sanctions aient appelé chacun à
l'exemplarité
on va parler des régionales et
départementales 1 qui pour le moment
sont prévues en juin le parlement va
être consultés cette semaine quel est
votre position vous sur un report de ces
élections
écoutez d'abord il faut que si l
élection il ya elle se déroule dans les
conditions de sécurité sanitaire les
plus strictes mais je dois dire qu'on ne
peut pas en permanence confiner la
démocratie dans notre pays
enfin les états unis élisent leur
président le portugal et livre le sien
les lander allemands procèdent à leur
lait à leur élection à un moment où
l'épidémie était parfois à des niveaux
très élevés ou la fac-ci nation n'était
pas développée et en france on ne
pourrait pas élire des conseillers
régionaux et des conseillers
départementaux donc il y à quelque chose
on sent bien y compris avec cette
consultation extrait ce qui n'était pas
prévu
durant ce week end des des maires par
les préfets on sent on sent bien que le
gouvernant
on n'a qu'une idée en tête c'est de
tenter de les reporter il est reporté le
plus loin possible
qu'est ce que vous pensez vous de cette
méthode de consultation des maires
écoutez le gouvernement s'en remet aux à
l'avis du conseil scientifique le
conseil scientifique ne tranche pas le
renvoie la balle au gouvernement qui lui
dit en gros si vous mettez en place les
des conditions de sécurité
vous devez pouvoir les organiser le
premier ministre lui même dit il ya
quelques jours que son option c'est
plutôt privilégié la date du mois de
juin
et puis d'un seul coup parce que je ne
sais pas qui se réveille
vendredi soir avec un avis différent
dans la majorité présidentielle et
préfets se sont se lance dans une
consultation express des 35000 maires de
france
donc il ya quelque chose d'un peu ça
ressemble de plus en plus à du
tripatouillage électoral donc encore une
fois moi je je je considère qu'il faut
faire respirer notre démocratie il faut
que toutes les conditions de sécurité
soient soient remplies et mais il faut
cesser de changer la règle en permanence
le gouvernement avait dit je consulte je
demande son avis au conseil scientifique
je demande aux formations politiques je
demande au groupe parlementaire il y
aura un débat
et puis il rajoute comme ça cette
consultation
tout ça n'est pas sérieux et encore une
fois ça ressemble de plus en plus à la
volonté d'un tripaille tout lui l'âge
électoral et gérard larcher lui dit que
si le gouvernement présente une loi de
record il saisira le conseil
constitutionnel vous soutenez sur ce
point écoute et encore une fois il faut
que le débat ait lieu
ce qui est et ce qui est là aussi
incompréhensible c'est que ce ce débat
cette situation elle et elle est connue
du gouvernement il ya eu au sénat comme
à l'assemblée nationale un certain
nombre de parlementaires qui vous fait
des propositions pour que la campagne
électorale le débat politique
l'organisation du scrutin puisse puisse
se dérouler avec des conditions strictes
le gouvernement n'en a suivi aucune de
ces recommandations
il n'a pas anticipé et donc c'est aussi
en cela que clairement il a les yeux
votre sentiment en tout cas c'est le
sentiment kindle c'est le sentiment
qu'ils donnent chacun a bien compris que
s'il pouvait échapper aux scrutins
locaux puisque la république en marche
n'est toujours pas implantées dans les
territoires il le ferait allègrement et
pour reporter ça a plus tard bien plus
tard jordan n'avait là pour le
rassemblement national lui dit que pour
des questions sanitaires il faudrait
dissocier régionales et départementales
qu'elle n'ait pas lieu le même jour mais
à quelques jours d'écart est ce que ça
c'est une proposition qui est entendable
pour vous encore une fois écouté on peut
prendre les transports collectifs
on peut rouvrir les écoles le le 26
avril
on peut le gouvernement se dit même prêt
à discuter de la réouverture des
établissements culturels des salles de
spectacles des ddd des magasins des
salles de sport mais par contre on ne
pourrait pas aller voter
la question c'est pas ce n'est pas
l'organisation du scrutin
l'organisation du scrutin on doit
pouvoir mettre en place un certain
nombre de règles qui qui fonctionne et
qui met nos concitoyens comme les
organisateurs des bureaux de vote dans
des conditions de sécurité strictes
c'est davantage la campagne campagne
électorale est bien est d'abord est ce
que est ce qu'il y à une campagne de
promotion de l'organisation de ces
élections qui a été lancée sur les
chaînes du service public
moi je n'en ai vue aucune est ce qu'il y
a une volonté de multiplier par exemple
l'envoi prise en charge par par l'état
des documents de propagande électorale
des différents candidats pour permettre
que l'information ait lieu est-ce que
lens vs que tous les dispositifs
justement pour imaginer la campagne de
différemment ont été envisagées rien de
tout cela et a maintenant deux mois
d'une consultation électorale dont la
date a été fixée les préfectures
s'organisent les les candidats déposent
y compris leurs dossiers
comme commence à préparer les choses à
deux mois d'une consultation le
gouvernement n'a pas imaginer quelles
pouvaient être les formes de cette
campagne électorale dans des conditions
nouvelles
et alors même qu'il a des propositions
sur la table tout ça n'est pas très
sérieux encore une fois et ça ressemble
davantage à du tripatouillage électoral
on va parler politique et de ce sondage
sur les régionales en île de france
oui en ile-de-france donc voilà il
pécresse a fait la course en tête la
gauche peut-elle avoir un espoir de
gagner si elle part divisée comme c'est
le cas à écouter moi j'essaye d'être
constant en politique et donc ma ma
constance elle est la même depuis
toujours c'est que la gauche ne peut
jamais gagner lorsqu'elle est divisé et
donc ce sondage il prouve sa une fois de
plus c'est à dire que quand même si je
sais bien que la politique ce n'est pas
de l'arithmétique c'est de la dynamique
justement il la dynamique c'est le
rassemblement est donc ce que je
constate c'est qu'en tout cas le total
des des minima des trois listes de
gauche principale eh bien ça fait
quasiment jeu égal avec la avec valérie
pécresse
donc on précise valérie pécresse elle a
plus de 30% au premier tour les trois
listes de gauche totalisent 34 35 % donc
c'est dire le potentiel le potentiel que
pourrait apporter justement dynamique de
rassemblement et donc moi je souhaite
que bien évidemment ce soit possible
d'assurer encore ceci possible
assurément au deuxième tour mais s'il y
a encore un chemin pour permettre ce
rassemblement dès le premier est bien il
faut tenter et encore un chemin pour
vous en tout cas il faut tout faire pour
que ce soit possible
c'est un nom puisqu'il ya vous avez
cosigné une tribune dans le journal du
dimanche sur la gratuité des transports
en c'est la proposition phare de la
campagne d'audrey pulvar qui est la
candidate contrôle du parti socialiste
pour ces régionales
est-ce que vous avez chiffré cette
mesure qui ont agressé des transports
est d'abord est audrey pulvar la
chiffrer l a dit que c'était un objectif
que c'est un horizon est donc bien
évidemment qu'il y aura des étapes bien
évidemment qu'il y aura des étapes est
d'ailleurs la première étape ça serait
notamment la gratuité pour les moins de
18 ans enfin le dans paris intra muros
et des jambes c'est désormais possible
parce que la ville de paris a pris un
certain nombre de mesures pour des
catégories
et ça ne serait pas possible pour
l'ensemble de la région ile de france
donc on voit bien que c'est un enjeu à
la fois de de pouvoir d'achat à un
moment où nos concitoyens notamment les
plus jeunes d'entre eux sont en grande
difficulté je pense aux étudiants à
toutes celles et tous ceux qui ont perdu
leur emploi et qui ont besoin justement
de cette mobilité et de ce pouvoir
d'achat supplémentaire y compris pour se
remettre en situation de trouver un
emploi de reprendre les études contre ce
sera possible
et c'est aussi un enjeu de liés à
l'environnement
oui il faut faire en sorte que dans les
années qui viennent on offre des
alternatives à l'automobile les autres
les alternatives à l'automobile c'est à
la fois les transports collectifs c'est
à la fois la marche à pied quand c'est
possible c'est à la fois le vélo c'est
un meilleur partage de l'espace public
et donc bien évidemment regardé toutes
les métropoles en france nantes
montpellier rennes dunkerque e nancy
tout ce débat sur la gratuité du
transport est aujourd'hui ouvert et donc
bien évidemment que c'est lestir si
c'est gratuit écoutez la question de
l'investissement dans les transports
publics en ile de france ça date pas
d'hier s'adapte ça ne date pas de ce
débat sous investis en dans les
transports collectifs en île de france
notamment
quand l'état était responsable des
transports dans dans en ile-de-france et
les notamment depuis depuis que
la gauche et avec jean paul huchon des
investissements massifs ont été faits
les choses commencent à changer en
matière de transport insuffisamment nos
tares en particulier en ile de france
mais cette question de l'investissement
elle est posée indépendamment de ce
débat sur la gratuité
oui il faut faire un faut avoir une
d'autres priorités à l'échelle du pays
sur les questions de transport il faut
privilégier les transports quotidiens
plutôt que cette course permanente à
gagner quelques minutes sur les lignes
sur le sur les lignes à grande vitesse
de paris vers la province c'est ça
l'enjeu est effectivement il faudra
continuer d'investir et d'investir
massivement dans les transports
oui ça demande des financements
importants mais il faut savoir ce qu'on
veut
si on veut changer en matière de encore
une fois d'utilisation des transports et
de partage de l'espace public plus
largement
on va parler d'un autre sondage sondage
ifop pour le journal du dimanche sur
l'élection présidentielle alors on est
loin ce n'est qu'un sondage mais quand
même il est révélateur d'un certain
nombre de choses ce sondage quels que
soient les cas de figure le second tour
oppose emmanuel macron à marine le pen
et surtout peut-être plus inquiétant
pour la gauche
personne à gauche n'est capable de
battre marine le pen qu'est ce que ça
dit de l'état de la gauche aujourd'hui
ça dit que justement elle est trop
fragmentée et elle est trop pemier t et
elle doit se rassembler et donc oui
c'est ça dis pas qu'elle est
considérablement affaiblie oui elle est
affaiblie mais elle est affaiblie
d'abord parce qu'elle est divisée et
donc c'est ça l'enjeu oui il faut une
offre qui faute à un bloc social
écologique qui soit fort et qu'ils
soient unis mais il n'y a pas
d'alternative au delà de ceux en dehors
d'un d'un rassemblement il un
rassemblement le plus large prenait
stéphane troussel ça me dit va y avoir
une belle photo avec avec des candidats
potentiels de tous les partis de gauche
mais enfin que ce soit sur la laïcité
sur l'europe sur l'énergie sur la
croissance les divisions sont
considérables est-ce que ça c'est
solvables jeu et bien moi je ne crois
pas ça moi je ne crois pas que justement
fait quand même pu le voir qui parlaient
une langue qu'on voit bien que tout le
ps est gêné c'est quand même compliqué
et bien moi je sur la croissance je ne
crois pas que nos écarts ce soit soit si
important que ça et il faut avoir la
volonté de chercher ce chemin commun il
faut avoir la volonté de justement de
chercher ce qui nous rassemble en
permanence plus tôt que ce qui nous
divise et on verrait bien finalement qu'
on est on est bien plus proche que
certains veulent nous dire en permanence
il est conseillé ce week-end que fabule
il scelle fabien roussel il investit
déjà candidat à la présidentielle est ce
que vous dites c'est trop tôt il
n'aurait pas dû mais c'est ça un débat
interne au
au parti communiste français j'ai
entendu les uns et les autres j'ai
entendu le porte parole du parti
communiste qui dit à la fois que dans le
moment dans lequel nous sommes c'est
bien normal qu'il y ait des débats de
personnalités d'orientation politique
mais j'ai pas entendu non plus
d'hostilité à l'idée qu'il faudra
chercher le rassemblement d'une manière
ou d'une autre et donc nous sommes dans
cette phase là vous savez des présidents
de la république et de ceux des second
tour d'élection présidentielle dont on
nous avait dit un an avant qu'ils
étaient déjà installés déjà figé il y en
a eu d'autres dans l'histoire de la vème
république
mais en tout cas ça dit à la fois le
chemin pour la gauche mais je dis aussi
les manuels macron et la république en
marche joue avec le feu a organisé ce
face-à-face inéluctable entre l'extrême
droite et lui c'est dangereux notamment
parce que christophe castaner lui dit
l'inversé dit que c'est la gauche qui
joue avec le feu en se trompant des
adversaires trop c'est mais c'est tout
de même extraordinaire qui lancent des
polémiques tous les matins contre la
gauche plutôt que l'extrême droite qui
de marlène schiappa frédéric vidal en
passant par par jean-michel black blanc
caire attaque tous les matins la gauche
sur je ne sais quel pseudo dérive alors
qu'eux ils épargnent en permanence
l'extrême droite
pire le ministre de l'intérieur explique
que désormais la représentante de
l'extrême droite est finalement plus
molle que la république en marche donc
ce jeu est dangereux pour la démocratie
est donc vraiment une présent la
république devrait ramener sa majorité à
la raison sur ce débat et faire en sorte
qu'il puisse y avoir un débat
démocratique un débat approfondi entre
deux options et deux options elle sans
quoi elles sont c est ce que
est-ce que c'est l'adaptation finalement
de la france aux standards les plus
libéraux éculé que que même jeu quand on
voit ce que fait le président by donne
aujourd'hui à quel point les états unis
sont en train de de tourner la page de
ce libéralisme qui a qui s'est déroulée
sur les économies occidentales depuis
des années et ce sera le mot de la fin
merci stéphane roussel
[Musique]